Are you guys ready?
Okay, bet. Let’s go, let’s go.
Bam.
Now we can start.
Guess what?
I’m your microbiologist.
Under all of this
is a lot of brains.
So, if I'm giving all this...
I want you to look good.
I want you to smell good.
I want your smile good.
I want it all.
I am freaking fired up for Love Island.
6’ 3”, solid steel and sex appeal
is not something you wanna walk by.
Naked Marco is a very pretty sight.
Hi, my name is Anna.
I’m going to become a detective.
But I actually already am.
If a guy asks me out,
I will find out his address,
I will find out his parent’s name.
I am a little bit of a stalker, yeah.
Let's go.
If you’re Dominican,
you’d better have the touch.
Growing up, they called me “La Melazas.”
So, slow and smooth...
that’s all it is.
I’m going to always meet your love language
and just show you the best time.
Mothers hide your sons.
My name is Kassy.
I'm a real estate student.
I get to work with my mom,
who's my boss,
but also my best friend.
I talk to her about everything...
unfiltered, maybe a little too much.
All right, let's do it.
Believe it or not,
I have never had a girlfriend.
I will write you love letters.
I am a total hopeless romantic.
I are here to find love.
Like now.
I am this professional girl,
and then when I'm not at work,
I'm absolutely f***king feral.
[animal yell]
I can't wait to walk in there,
see my man,
shove my tongue down his throat.
Football has been everything
for the majority of my life.
I’m a dog on and off the field.
I let the dog loose
when it comes to chasing these girls.
I’m going after what I want.
I love, love.
Like, everywhere I go,
I'm looking for love.
I'm on the dating apps.
I'm looking for my man.
Like, I don't understand
why I haven't found him yet.
God, I need you to send me a man.
Tall, handsome, athletic.
It hasn't worked yet.
You see, like, the 250 pounds, wrestler...
but in the inside,
I’m kind of like a big softie.
I cannot wait to get into the villa
and find my feet.
and find my fairytale princess.
[humming wedding march]
That's crazy.
I'm looking for my husband.
I cannot wait to get started.
Oh, baby.
Was that good, though?
Ahh! Yes!
Okay, good.